Tom
private payrolls Rose by 145 000 jobs
and 145 000 in March well below
expectation ADP says Okay so this was a
topic that everybody was talking about
the last
24 hours
um this is down from an upwardly revised
261 000 in February down below Dow Jones
estimate of 210 000 the first quarter
hiring average around 175 000 jobs a
month a sharp reduction from the average
of 397 just a year ago in first quarter
okay according to adp's Chief Economist
Nella Richardson the March payroll data
is one of several signals that the U.S
economy is slowing down employers are
pulling back from a year of strong
hiring and pay growth with pay growth
now in inching down job growth was
almost evenly split between services and
goods producing firms which is unusual
the US economy is heavily service
oriented so the services sector
generally produces much stronger hiring
gains Tom why should we care about this
number
so there's a couple numbers to care
about this morning and first of all
happy Good Friday to everybody and
hopefully we give you some good ideas
and some things to use with these stats
as you manage your life and your
business
there's a couple things going on here
Pat do you ever have like your favorite
basketball team plays and you see a
couple things that happen and what
happened
maybe at the net really started like 45
seconds ago at the other end of the
court and things were forming and they
come together or it's your favorite
football team and you see something
happen you say it really wasn't the
touchdown you have to go two plays
before that momentum being built up
correct and things happening well here's
here's what's interesting happening and
Rob if you could be ready with the chart
I sent you
right now there are three things that
are moving together right now that are
very bad
it is the change in job openings is
dropping so number the number of job
openings is dropping when we saw the uh
layoffs a week ago with meta remember
part of the meta was where we're laying
off 4 000 more people but we're
canceling 5 000 open jobs so people that
day that went online looking hey Matt
has got like 5 000 engineering jobs poof
they were gone so they call that net
9000 so they eliminated nine thousand
jobs so those job openings are going
away at an increasing rate number one
and number two the private payrolls
Rising less than expected means there
was hiring but less hiring than was
expected number two and then number
three the percent change in quits is
dropping through the floor
let me explain quits the government
actually tracks a number of people that
quit jobs and this is before they get an
unemployment check because when your
social security number is with the IRS
and you're going to get a W-2 they know
who you work for and if you change jobs
at the end of the year you get two W-2s
one for this job one for that job so the
government can track when your social
security number moves from one company
to another and they call that a quit or
a job change and so they get the stats
so what you have everything coming
together here
um there's a chart that if can they see
that right now perfect so you take a
look at this this is by regions and
there's a government chart that you can
look at any time you want called joltz
j-o-l-t-s which is job openings and
labor turnover survey and it'll tell you
like the temperature of your region of
what's going on for the job economy and
right now
job openings are down lowest since 2021
layoffs are up and it's not just Tech
and quits are down so people with jobs
are not quitting at the same rate they
were in any of the previous three years
Pat remember it was fashionable to quit
walk across the street tell them and I
want to work from home and I want to
bring my dog to work and I only want to
work four days all those things and I
want 20 more and employers were kind of
desperate for workers and so during
covet sometimes they said yes so the
workers kind of had this leverage point
and as you've said on the podcast a lot
of times workers overplayed their hand
because three years later they're
looking for layoffs and the boss is
saying okay who took me to the bank
what's unique about this though Tom so
what's unique about this what what is
the same these all of these things
coming together are saying that we have
a very soft job market right now and
you've got the Wall Street Journal CNBC
and the official business magazine of
China Forbes they're all saying the same
thing saying look out the word is look
out it's like this is think of it this
way Pat there is a check engine light on
the jobs part of the US economy we have
installed we haven't pulled over yet but
when you take a look at everything here
job openings down
fewer people hired and fewer people
quitting that means the entire job
market is nervous well maybe let me read
this other stuff so this kind of gives
you a little bit of what you're trying
to say job cuts are almost up 400 this
year as jobless claims rise okay so this
is a specifics the job Cuts have nearly
sharpened risen sharply with roughly job
Cuts uh risen sharply with roughly 270
000 job Cuts so far this year 396
increase from last year what was that
percent
396 percent oh so that's big that's a
very big number on what they're talking
about the tech sector was hit the
hardest for job Cuts according to
accounting for 38 of all the layoffs
this year Financial companies came in
second accounting for 11 of layoffs
Giants such as Amazon Google and meta
fired over 10 000 and it's not even
slowing down Adam you were going to say
something yeah well look if you're
anything like me like I'm reading all
these reports right here and if you
focus on all this it is so easy to get
anxious and stressed out like if you
just read any of these headlines JB
Diamond words of the banking crisis has
raised the odds of recession U.S health
system will go bankrupt the next few
years more signs pointing towards an
eminent slowdown private payrolls rolls
154 000 below expectations higher
jobless claims more jobs Cuts more jobs
Cuts bank failures High inflation it's
like holy what does this mean for
me right because at the end of the day
Tom is more of a macro guy and I'm more
of a personal finance guy you could take
all this stuff and you have to look in
the mirror and be like okay what am I
going to do you know how they say that
like degrees pay fees and skills pay the
bills you have to look in the mirror and
see am I where I need to be skill-wise
am I you know Warren Buffett says the
number one way to be inflation proof or
Recession Proof is to actually just be
good at your job yeah okay so with all
this chaos going on in the economy me
it's so easy to feel overwhelmed like
I'm sure Vinnie's head's about to
explode with all these numbers I'm gonna
throw up but but if you're Vinnie yeah
you're Rob if you're me are you showing
up to work every day are you putting in
the work are you improving are you out
working are you out strategizing and
that's the only way to outlast in a
rough economy because every every day
there's a new report the economy is a
recession inflation actually we're
getting better oh no yeah hold on stock
market Bitcoin up down I don't know what
to make of it but if I'm you
I have to take a deep breath and be like
okay what can I do to control what's
going on you know they say that there's
two things in life things that matter
and things that you can't control or
where you can focus is where those two
things intersect you can't control
everything and not everything matters
but where they diverge is where you
should focus you know I would sum it up
step up in the macro and and thank you
for the nudge is if you've got a good
job keep it
right now is the wrong time to walk
across the street for a five percent
difference in salary if you've got if it
show some loyalty if you own a business
and so many people so many value
chainers out there are business owners
when we had our last live event it's
like 70 of people in the audience are
business owners and thank you for your
support right now is a time to look
around and if you need to make an
upgrade of a key position you probably
have a hungry person that might show up
at the door as opposed to a couple years
ago so maybe now is the time to make an
upgrade and now is the time to show some
love to your great people and the people
that maybe wore pains you may be
opportunities to upgrade them now and
Pat you've we've had this conversation
many times I know we brought this up a
couple podcasts ago about whether it's
good time to ask for a raise stay loyal
loyalty what's being rewarded you know
over covid
things were so up things that went down
but I know you have strong feelings on
what employees should be doing in this
type of situation and how employers
should respond to that right yeah look I
mean I understand the message you're
given your message is hey you know uh uh
be careful reading a lot of these
stories because you're gonna be scared
and you're going to be this and you know
focus on yourself and yeah you're right
all of that stuff is fine but people are
here because they actually want to know
like what's going to happen to the
economy right they're here because they
want to get our feedback our opinion on
is this the time are we getting close to
it what should we do and you know they
get to make a decision for themselves we
don't have the answers we're just
processing having conversations together
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]